what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
this video probably should have come out
last week but I'm busy closing on my
house um I don't even think about having
a video last week and I actually did not
plan to have a video this week so we're
gonna talk about for being beyond
omega-level now with regards to our
discussion on this for you guys who are
new here to comics explained we always
start out with the origin story and then
we jump into his powers now under normal
circumstances we would say the origin
story is not necessary for Thor because
he is so popular however I was having a
conversation with a person and I had
basically mentioned the name Steve
Rogers and she didn't know who that was
I told her Captain America and she
understood
so always one thing to remember guys and
it's a hard lesson I've had to learn
over the years of being a comic book
reader just because we know doesn't mean
everybody knows so Thor is the son of
the all-father of Norse pantheon gods
known as Onan and the elder goddess Gaea
now because of this genetic combination
Thor is the strongest of all the gods of
Asgard and is destined to succeed his
father Odin as all father once odin
passes away now as for the comic book
origin Thor was created in 1962 by Stan
Lee his brother Larry Lieber and Jack
Kirby in debuted and journey into
mystery number 83 and what we learn is
that Odin wanted his son to learn
humility mostly because Thor was kind of
a jerk who would go get drunk all the
time so we sent him to earth without any
memory of his previous life as a god
where Thor became a guy named Donald
Blake who basically just practiced
medicine now while he was on a trip in
Norway Donald Blake hides in a cave to
avoid some aliens that he encounters as
you do when you are heroic hero and
finds a walking stick that he would
later use to strike a rock and act that
would turn Blake back into Thor giving
him all his memories back and the
walking stick into the hammer of Mjolnir
now following this Thor would be both
Donald Blake and himself practicing
medicine as Blake in his everyday life
and battling some of Earth's most
dangerous threats as Thor and as part of
the Avengers so obviously there's a lot
more to Thor's character than that and I
have a ton of Thor related videos that
you can dive into if you want to learn
more about his character but that pretty
much is the essence of how Thor came to
be one of the most popular heroes in the
Marvel Universe also the fact that he
was created in the 1960s when Marvel was
arguably at its most popular now this
brings us to exactly what Thor's powers
are now as we stated earlier
Thor is literally a god and it should
come as no surprise
being a god grants him some pretty
impressive powers first of all it means
that Thor's longevity is much much
longer than that of a normal human what
this means is that while Thor is not
immortal he will live for thousands of
years
before he eventually dies now this not
only comes from Thor's Asgardian
physiology but also from eating golden
apples grown by the goddess at dune I
think it's how you pronounce it which
not only allows the Gods to live a long
life but to maintain their peak physical
condition for an increased length of
time as well now in addition to this
longevity Thor possesses superhuman
strength on an extremely ridiculous
scale to get an idea of how strong he is
he has battled and defeated some of the
strongest characters and the marvel
universe including abomination who's
given the Hulk a run for his money on
more than one occasion but was defeated
by Thor with one punch
Thor's broken shields created by the
Silver Surfer who has the power cosmic
basically a fraction of Galactus power
he snapped cables made of adamantium one
of the most durable metals in the Marvel
Universe and has even been able to trade
punches with the Hulk himself now
perhaps the most impressive feat of
Thor's strength that we've seen was when
he managed to force the Midgard serpent
a dragon large enough to coil itself
around the earth multiple times forced
it to release its grip on earth using
only his bare hands that was worth
noting here that Thor's strength can be
augmented even further if he enters a
state of consciousness called the
Warriors madness which allows him to
become 10 times stronger but eliminates
his ability to discern between friends
and enemies placing everyone and his
immediate vicinity in danger now the
funny thing about warriors madness and I
don't remember when it was introduced
into Marvel Comics but is basically a
blood lusted Thor it's when he's so
caught up in the heat of battle that he
basically just kind of snaps Thor not
only possesses superhuman strength but
is also practically invulnerable now
Thor is immune to all human diseases and
toxins which explains why he's able to
drink a copious amount of alcohol
without ever getting drunk which is
something that I wish I could do Thor
has also withstood energy blasts from
Celestials and even Odin himself in
addition to being pretty much involved
or possesses a healing factor that can
repair virtually any damage that Thor
sustains and superhuman stamina that
allows him to engage in battle for
extended periods of time without growing
tired and of course as they got a
thunder Thor was able to command
forces of nature like rain wind snow and
lightning which you can use in battle
against his enemies a couple of things
to explain here in the story The
Incredible Hulk the end Thor dies as a
result of a nuclear holocaust that takes
place across the world I don't know how
to explain that Marvel just did it
because they didn't want Thor to be in
the picture under normal circumstances
force should be able to withstand a
nuclear explosion and nuclear radiation
if he goes back to Asgard and you know
goes to their whole medicine process
assuming his body can't do it on his own
I cannot give you an answer to the
questions of how it was he survived that
and other what-if stories like that now
the other thing about this is people are
inevitably going to ask how does Thor
rank in comparison to storm I can't give
you an answer to that question I would
say just on the surface storm has a
better command of the storms than Thor
does but some people will also say
Thor's a God who has power over
basically weather itself and so Thor is
the one who's more powerful than storm
honestly it depends on which character
that you like the most if we had to
provide a definitive answer
storm is the one who probably has better
control over weather because that's kind
of her thing Thor just like hits people
with a hammer he can do that stuff you
know control weather from time to time
you don't see it all that often usually
to see him like using lightning he can I
mean they're two different characters
would that are part of two separate
groups that crossover occasionally but
with with storm being like an
omega-level character who's basically
able to control the elements being an
elemental herself more or less I would
say that she's probably more powerful
than Thor is now there is one story that
a lot of people reference and a lot of
people usually get it wrong there is a
story in Black Panther issue number 25
that is part of the original Civil War
event where Thor fought storm and I
think storm overpowered him that was not
Thor that was the Thor clone Ragnarok so
one thing to keep in the back of your
heads whenever you see that that's not
actually Odin's son but the Thor has at
his disposal a two primary offensive
weapons that make him even more
formidable in battle first and almost
definitively the most famous is his
hammer
now Mjolnir was forged from uber metal
by the dwarves from a fallen star at the
request of Thor's father Odin now this
would later be changed by Jason Aaron in
his Mighty Thor series to basically
state that the hammer actually houses a
gigantic sentient storm called mother
storm that's equal to o Dhin in power
but because of the fact that we're
talking about like pre Ragnarok
that doesn't really apply but even if we
did apply it it wouldn't make any
difference because without the added
power of the mother storm the classic
version of Thor's hammer allowed him to
carry out some pretty ridiculously
impressive feats like knocking over
Galactus and cracking the armour of the
celestial exit are now since the
Celestials themselves are considered a
universal level threat the fact that
Thor can damage their armor with his
hammer is extremely impressive in and of
itself and the owner is also the means
by which Thor is able to fly which is a
common source of confusion among readers
but as far as we seen in the comics Thor
is not able to fly without the
assistance of his hammer one panel
people usually refer to when it comes to
Thor's ability to quote-unquote
fly without his hammer comes from
Avengers squadron supreme annual in 1998
and this there's an instance where were
Hyperion and Thor fight each other Thor
loses his hammer and seems to continue
to fly that's actually not the case is
stated in the comic that Thor cannot fly
without his hammer
the Hammers knocked out of his hand and
Thor starts falling and then eventually
is defeated but even then it is still
kind of weird and it's kind of
questionable because it happened so fast
so I guess you could kind of interpret
that how you want to but the long and
short of it is that on the whole Thor
cannot fly without his hammer
I haven't read every single comic in
existence so I'm sure somebody somewhere
may have a comic where Thor was actually
able to fly without his hammer I'm just
not aware of it but the other primary
offensive weapon and Thor's Arsenal is
the Thor force which is basically an
extremely powerful divine force that was
once wielded by Odin of course is called
the odinforce when his wielded by Odin
himself but later passed on to Thor now
since the odinforce
or Thor force is pretty much limitless
we don't know what the full extent of
his capabilities are but we do know that
Thor has channeled it using his hammer
and Thor was able to decapitate the
destroyer armor which was designed to
defeat Celestials which is pretty much
also indestructible and that Odin was
able to use it to destroy a galaxy now
if we draw the logical conclusion that
Thor is or will one day be able to wield
the odinforce in his own capacity in the
same way that Odin can then we can
presume that he would also be able to
destroy a galaxy which would undoubtedly
place him beyond omega-level in fact
quite far beyond omega-level this is
especially important because omega-level
is a term that's used to denote a
planetary threat now in recent years
Thor's power level has seemingly been
toned down at the
by Marvel since Thor returned from the
dead and J michael Straczynski 's run
well he is still an extremely powerful
character he's never quite achieved the
level of power that he had before the
events of Ragnarok so while I think that
it's likely that Thor is still in omega
level threat or perhaps even beyond
Omega level it's not as cut-and-dry if
we look at the events since Ragnarok
especially if we look at the current
version of Odin Sun which has been
deemed unworthy to wield his hammer and
is no longer in possession of the Thor
force but regardless guys I know how to
include every single feat that Thor has
performed and maybe I should maybe you
should just be like a respect Thor video
like those respect threads it is
interesting to kind of see those things
unfold but if you guys are new here to
come this explain it make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
robb pork if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]